you do a lot of morning show gigs yeah
like you know I do stand-up all the time
I'm a stand-up comedian improviser by
trade you had me on one of the most fun
experiences my life as I was on the show
in Chicago and I attempted to eat two
Italian beef sandwiches in under a
minute
I remember that and it did not work but
yeah I go all over the country and I
like to do morning shows they can be
their own little pieces of performance
art if you really approach them from the
right angle we actually put together a
little montage of some of your morning
show appearances small markets across
the country very early in the morning
well small markets I did Omaha let's
take a look you know training
yeah I've been eating only celery which
actually costs more calories than you
ingest so it's an excellent way to lose
weight you and America didn't buy it
yeah I look like I'm as insane as I am
New York City so you got this movie
coming out transformers
[Applause]
it has no sleep are you going there so
that was that was the premiere you know
a lot of people do you guys are both
comedians and a lot of people do a
spit-take but yeah many who can't
believe something's he spit water I he
could and that that was the premiere I
sort of invented this move which is the
dribble take and so you don't spit it
just sort of falls on to your chest and
where it's something that we're probably
all headed to at some point there we go
[Applause]
I like that you made us wait for it that
was you know what I know wake anyone
wait any longer
you know I've made a terrible mistake
[Laughter]
you